i'll show you exactly how and why you  should build your own ssd this treblet  ssd with the custom m.2 inside costs you  280 bucks we are going to need two  things this kit from trableet that  includes everything we need along with  an m.2 pci express ssd the one that i'm  using is a sabrint rocket ssd we're  going to take off the baggie and the top  half grab our ssd there's a little notch  in here so it only goes in one way go  ahead and slip it in here at an angle  push it down and grab our screw grab our  little thermal pad apply it to the top  here peel off the other side all right i  felt that contact right there i just  screw them in with the included little  screwdriver let's get into why this  thing is so much better in pretty much  every way compatibility price point does  not slow down goes up to 25.50 right and  26 53